re します
を4つは酒に呼び出して
me
安島さーん
来てくれたんですねここだら誰も見られないん
今日はあなたに聞いてもらいます
ああああああああ
パパ
ああああああ
そっかー
ブーバー者キュ中風家じゅうブーバーンねよく言えたなぁ
富山県ユーチューバー俺一人で十分だ
残念だ
午後あなたの死に場所です
決着をつけましょう
いいだろうお前何で指先一つん
今日再生するのまま指先ってことなんでバックガンというもので対戦していきたいと
おもいます
今回はですねタカラトミーさんの新商品などで助っ人を用意しております
たワーキングさんですどうぞじゃあ者
たまきんぐの城ならー
じゃあ今日は麦飯という所ってよってきましたよ
ぱっくダンデー
これはこのボール状態から指先で端中としてパシャッと変形して遊ばせる保護者です何
で十分な
どうゆうばくあ説明していきますはいここの部分に m って書いてるんですけれども
ここに磁石が入ってこれがうまいことこの六角形のパク子ああっ
環境バックコアに乗っかると場所実際にやってみましょう
m のを殺したに知っておいて
バッカー主主をおおおお
ブーバー今回助っ人
頼んでおりますどうぞいやー
yeah
me
ブーバーし
あああああ
おっさん三大産地へみたいいやつ目と3つ目になりましたーーー
かあですねいつも re away 用意していただきましたあーー今回のルールは
ですね pa ございましたティエポロさせたチームが勝利となりますまず第一あー
りーダーであるんですけど
ブーブー j
amaran
yearly ないそういうえここにスタートって書いておりましてもうこのがうって
言ってレバーもうねあのこのロングブリッジを超えたとこの穴に入りそういうことよ
来週的にパシャッと言わ言われ
[音楽]
ブーバー主人公がティ
充てる白れーわー者ピザトリックまっすぐ転がりやすい
どうぞじゃあ俺がこのグリーンタートルデー
これぞロックすっ
はっはっはつける
じゃあ僕はリプレイどのことを予防ああ
安全子なんてあっ浜で頑張って登って大蛇里奈
やってみましょう所有さあではよっち
いきたいとおもいます yeah んじゃねぇ
てくれー
バグラー
中色
[拍手]
me
だって僕に前ですが全然違う
[音楽]
重力が見れる
ああああああああ
wh
goo
無料していけるぜええ結構強めに襲われ
だろうじゃ行きまーすイェーイ
cm
me
ブーブーすぐちょっと強いやればいい指のブーブー
ん
yeah
me
格安はもう技術なじゃあ
picasa 2週目パワー中
goo
c ん
wh
大内地えーい
car
goo .ne.jp
ところ r これはリベリがこれ
rai もうパソコン見てみましょう入っできますよ
オゾンにこれはき鎧こべっ大会する牡丹園や犬
荒島にゃんわー
マザコンのタイプのみでもこれメロン玉 zard
終了誰ここのカーブをうまいことを使い good a
イェイ安全に僕はクリアしてほしいなと思っていやしようぜ
ああああああ
野郎だけだよ八洲
こうでしょだからあんまり真ん中に行くと落ちちゃうんだよな
いますバックナーンするとここ
ran
ni
ok じゃ行くぜ
これはねぇ2彼っていうガー集2
あああっは
うううう車
うわーこやっぱりな理由ぞハイバック座
中途よわぁ
me
dare
4まできますいきます爆がー集
かぁああ
ああああああ
me
そっと付いたんだろなに行く前というのを嫌がってしまいますよし
[音楽]
同じことを繰り返しているもう決めろ
イブラ者山路理解できますもあふらー収納大
goo
huh
mar
ズーカっていうくらい rae
dje rei さんのアリーナ
会いましょう reirei だろ富川
ジャンル do a
が実は距離こっちゃないとんじゃないこれもう
て blue sea ほど
amaran
ブーバは c パティていきパンヌード
たのにあたり多分バグアン can ああ
goo
[音楽]
nan
ながらもだねぇいくぜ決めちゃうよこれ
バックガーン種類あああああ
ん
[音楽]
強めつよねーよねっタラコったら俺の得意分野で多分配色決めるように頑張ってよ本当
に
パッカーシュッ
マヤすぎると葉月ほど植え水なぁ
このバックラーの僕がどうですか皆さん僕の指が凍って怖くてショップいますよ
ハイバックがー
周囲と4
me
弱いんでうっていう思いで来ますラフィアチェーンわー
なーいって走って3月度いくってくれ
池田そうなんで多分大丈夫じゃねーな
いくぜバックナーん
ん
はああああぁぁぁ
って言え木目調の日ですよちょっと訳ですよバナー
数れパワー
はぁはぁん
me
あっはぁ4番丸は載っていなければもうは奇跡的やるぜイエーイ
あー3をくぐりああああいやこれをトリック習得名付けだよイェーイ
rar
まだ眠いたさあそうですよねいいショップでしたはいこれはねびっくりだウィッグ
シュートですから第8枚になっ
これを
入って目に入ってめっあっている服どころという声 the
第8の有田遺跡あいなるっていいじゃん扉まだ閉まってるんですよまびら取ると秒わー
これでもえっ
は上下してるー
ここの桜食ったりぞ言ってるよああ
2回連続生後サイトたメテオるってことで麗霊夢はくれ
シャア1ならここからスタートしていただき上げ下げするあのピラーを超えて絵
チャットちゃんヌードル
オーラやこれはね意外といけそうででもステージをんだと思っ
まあ歳まくがー
スーッとああ
me
じゃあ行って目サンダーが行くで
麦芽は
んあー
[音楽]
car
止めた変わりますが僕が破城槌んだ
聞います1綺麗ですバッグガーン
きゅっちそう
めっちゃポリス胸がないなぁ俺
うわーんだけどプレッシャーちょっとちょっとず耐え可愛ければくわー
しゅっぱーー2あっうっあああぁああ
renarena
言ってろれた
まあああああアニメ者の自分感じじゃ
ran あああああ
それが終わり0
ブーブー soiree しましょう shoji ああああああ
ヤバすぎ w はーいじゃあそれも
4 goo
dare
atan ヴェゼルこれを持ってくかダークラーってきて
ブーバーンたリプレイ
なーるほどこれはタイミングよくもう直線ちょっと元値の栗を
見えてくださいですこれパレウイングロードとしては右足欲しいなとだいぶ有田
見てみましょうジャンルああああチーズますさんが3 o 型
頑張ります
初質問バッハ
cororo でーっま
rar
car
yeah
when
ん
rar
me
ハロー時期予想してなかった re
すごい所なんてくださいはい
我々はうわーどうしますよこれギャレットしないよねやっていいでしょ
ちょっと琉映
anb 3 none
barbapapa ああああ
ハゲたちや今わーすごい
凍っねーなんでしょキレイ館
いやまぁ冗談 parano デー
me
car
[音楽]
teal
me
rar あった
愛的で皆さん枕どうでしたあああああああいいいい
んですマット等防ぐ盛り上がったわけなんですけどもこちらのバックラー全国のお姉
さんに振っておりまーす
皆さん買って遊んでみてくださいそしてですね4月の1日からアニメ爆丸バトル
プラネットもやってるみたいなので是非皆さんそちらを見てみてください
爆丸体験したい人多いと思うんですけど全国の街が直球
写真
そこで体験できますので是非皆さん行ってみてください
うでー by arthur
待って待って待って待ってるんですけどねはラー難しいんだ違う
罰芸能をご用意していた
米国のヴァグナーショップクレバーだじゃあ罰ゲームの港へ案内します
こちらです
dare